[Music]
it has become a tradition here on the
bioneer to post a new batman workout at
the start of each new year
the idea is to tie together many of the
concepts i've discussed throughout the
year
with a program that will develop real
functional cross-modal performance
batman is the ideal fictional
inspiration for the kind of training i
covet
here's the imaginary peak of human
performance he is at once strong
fast agile and extremely intelligent
this year i wanted to do things a little
bit differently the aim is to approach
batman as though he were a client
looking for a functional training
program
rather than a general program to build a
number of different traits like batman
i'm going to instead imagine that bruce
wayne is a real person
with the specific set of skills that he
needs to develop and maintain
all with an extremely busy schedule
what's really interesting to me about
batman is that he shows how multiple
skills and tools are better than just
one
it seems to me that a lot of people are
low key training to be better fighters
these are not competitive boxers but
regular folk who still feel an
underlying pressure to be tough
in quotation marks to many people the
reason to lift heavy weights is so that
they could use that strength in a fight
of course this is missing the point that
technique is more important than raw
strength
when it comes to punching power and more
to the point fighting is not the only
expression of strength and fitness
i much prefer george's herbert's notion
of being
strong to be useful i get more
confidence knowing that if i need to run
away from danger i could do so quickly
and without tiring
that i could climb over obstacles or
lift another person over one shoulder
and help them get to safety
these same skills help you to get places
quickly help people move furniture and
focus on work
which is why batman training is
something that everyone should concern
themselves with
batman and in fact any action hero
really epitomized this idea
when you see batman take on a gang of
thugs or chase catwoman across rooftops
what are just as impressive as his
fighting prowess are his parkour
proprioception stealth strategy reflexes
quick decision making and cardio the
biggest challenge
most people would face when trying to be
batman for real would be getting tired
out almost
instantly or getting knocked out from a
single punch or jumping from a height
and twisting an ankle
or being really cold on top of a
building and getting a headache
this is why lifting heavy weights won't
make you batman and focusing on being
tough
is often just an ego trip trying to be
batman
obviously isn't an eager trip functional
coaches tend to choose exercises based
on specificity
these are exercises that either resemble
the movement the individual is training
for
or that utilize and strengthen specific
muscle groups and underlying traits
used in those actions this means the
exercises should have
near transfer if you want to get better
at chopping wood
it's no good to perform bench press and
squats instead you need something that
is similarly ballistic
that is simultaneously a pull and a push
and that incorporates a twisting element
the therapy effect
such exercises will train the body in
the transverse plane
meaning they incorporate twisting and
this will build stronger
more explosive serratus muscles so what
are the skills and traits that batman
training should address
work capacity batman needs to maintain
high power output for a long duration
strength endurance is as important if
not more important than maximum strength
cardio batman runs a lot while wearing a
lot of armor
running jumping and climbing batman
needs parkour skills
batman's strength must be relative to
his weight throwing a name
batman needs to train his throwing arm
for hurling batarangs he also needs
precise aim and so likely should train
his senses
max strength whether lifting a heavy
barrel grappling an opponent or lifting
open a door batman definitely needs some
max strength
what's important is that his strength is
developed on all planes
rotation is as important if not more
important than strength in the sagittal
and frontal planes
harden the bones to reduce injury
psychomotor vigilance
batman needs to be sharp and focused
even after a long night of chasing bad
guys
and equilibrioception or balance batman
needs body awareness
when balancing along beams or fighting
multiple combatants
explosiveness as it relates to jumping
and throwing punches
neck strength this may seem oddly
specific but it's important to reduce
concussions
and can even aid with visual tracking
thanks to the link between the neck and
the senses
grip strength whether climbing or
holding onto an assailant grip strength
is crucial
stability batman needs stability in the
hips knees and core to prevent injury
and enhances grappling and running rapid
decision making
mental toughness in spades there are
many more traits and skills that batman
can benefit from too but which should be
considered less important
things like mobility batman doesn't need
to be able to get his leg behind his
head but a certain amount of mobility
will aid in combat climbing and injury
prevention
i also strongly believe that batman
could benefit from being ambidextrous
with all that in mind let's now select
some exercises for batman
based on the specificity principle
sled push or pull rope climbing medicine
ball rotational throw or sledgehammer
medicine ball slam kettlebell swings
muscle ups
gamma cast atlas swings rock climbing
tire flipping
sandbags snatch band pull and push body
weight rows
military press lizard crawls skipping
loaded carries
isometric neck pushes
ab roll out bent rows hill sprints 100
up
rocking weighted squat jumps high rep
push-ups pull-ups squats
v-ups and burpees and heavy squat bench
press and deadlift
lateral jumps these are skater hops
renegade rows long distance running
trail running
heavy bag training and battle ropes this
is by no means a comprehensive list
but it's certainly a good starting point
so now how would we possibly go about
programming something like this
this is a criticism that some people
have made of my training style in
general
that it's impossible to train such a
variety of different traits and skills
if you have a busy schedule
people accuse me of having no life me
the guy talking about batman on youtube
well firstly no one has a life right now
so i don't know what you're so smug
about
secondly i still have plenty of time for
do maternal and my family come to think
of it
in all seriousness i only train for
around four to six hours a week and i
take whole weeks off regularly
nobody would accuse me of not having any
other interests or never taking it easy
i run several businesses and i'm a
full-time dad this list of exercises is
not that much more than you would expect
to train if you're using a bodybuilding
bro split
or calisthenics regime as for sequencing
the key is to perform heavy and complex
movements at the start
with lower reps then move to higher rep
low weight exercise
and then eventually finish with cardio
and work capacity training
this is similar in structure to a power
building routine
this way you can train every type of
twitch muscle fiber train all
energy systems train plyometric strength
as well as isometric strength
and avoid injury we're not doing heavy
compound lifts for high reps a lacrosse
fit staying away from heavy dangerous
movements especially when fatigued
is good advice for active batman
training in general
not only do we want to avoid injury
obviously we also don't want to
completely fatigue our nervous system
and therefore have no energy left for
the actual
job of fighting crime which i take it
we're all gonna do after this
this is something that a lot of people
don't recognize when writing training
programs
for specific skills sports or tasks the
aim isn't always to lift as much as
humanly possible
or to completely tax the individual some
people have commented about bruce lee's
gym cards that show he squatted 95
pounds
for 3x10 reps they take this as evidence
that he was
weak but bruce lee was a martial artist
first and foremost
it wouldn't make any sense for him to
train to the point of complete failure
and to thus be unable to strike the bag
the following day
moreover bruce lee would use
compensatory acceleration to increase
his rate of force development and neural
drive
even with a lighter weight it's all
about intent rather than the weight on
the bar
emotional [ __ ] this is why bar speed is
such a useful measure
if anything this shows that bruce lee
understood the principles of athletic
training
well before his time and the same should
definitely be true for bruce wayne
you might expect a batman training
program to involve lots of
hugely ridiculous lifts but in reality
it should be
far from that in fact if i were really
writing a training program for bruce
wayne
i would write it so that he never
performed his one rep max while he was
on active duty
if this were a periodized program we
might include that to get him to a
certain level of strength
and then simply aim to keep him there
this is much easier to do and would
allow him to continue delivering his
best effort
when punching the joker nor do all these
exercises need to be present in every
workout we can mix and match
performing high rep finishes and
resistance cardio work at the end of a
workout
also allows us to push ourselves and dig
deep to find reserves of strength and
determination
batman's willpower is his real
superpower and you can train that just
like a muscle
don't aim to make training comfortable
aim to make it cold
wet and grueling moreover it puts us in
a fatigued state and highly
physiologically aroused
which is where we can train for more
psychomotor vigilance and more
focus here's the thing batman needs to
be able to perform under extreme fatigue
and pressure
he needs to stay calm when he's just
been in a 10 minute fight this is what
makes the difference between saving the
day
and being a useless wreck and this is
what we see when we look at special
forces training
this is the kind of thing as well that
pat mcnamara talks about a lot
pat is an ex-spec ops fitness guy who
trains people by getting them to run
long distances
and then make precise shots with
firearms this kind of training is truly
valuable if you want to be a real action
hero
because it's a million miles from doing
the same thing whilst you're completely
rested in a safe environment
while batman doesn't use guns the same
thing applies to any other task that
requires attention
and a steady hand such as disarming a
bomb
this would be a perfect opportunity then
to practice ambidexterity or target
practice or both simultaneously
and it's at this point that our training
goes beyond being a tough
cross modal workout and turns into
something that batman might actually
find useful
and as jc santana from the institute of
human performance explained to me
losing concentration for even a second
during a fight is a game over
without psychomotor vigilance you'll
find that your movements start to become
less fast and explosive
there's a difference between grinding
and staying sharp and some of this comes
down to self-management and tactics
training cannot become rote or
absent-minded if we really want to work
out like batman
again this has huge benefits outside of
batman training too
psycho motor vigilance is a huge game
changer when it comes to injury
prevention
and accident avoidance it could
certainly prevent a lot of traffic
accidents
batman is required to operate in an
extremely unpredictable and changing
environment then
he might be running while carrying a
bomb one minute then dodging lasers
whilst injured the next to be effective
his training needs to reflect that
unpredictability
this is something i've talked about a
fair bit this year to develop skills
that are truly transferable
we can't always train on flat surfaces
with round bars
better than a pull-up is a pull-up on a
tree branch better than yet another
squat is a squat on a sloped surface
note that this only becomes true once
you have mastered the fundamental
movement
through repetition again a true batman
workout would need periodization to
account for all of this
think about muscles not only in terms of
force production but in terms of input
and output
that's to say that your muscles provide
crucial feedback about the world around
you
the forces acting against you and your
current position and must then
organize themselves around this movement
to generate useful force in the moment
you can't separate force production from
the visual motor landscape
without falling on your butt this is why
we need to learn to produce power
in unexpected ways if we want to be
truly functional and this is why
something like a sandbag snatch is so
useful
because every single repetition is going
to be different not only because of the
unusual shape of the bag
but also because of the shifting center
of gravity within the bag
it's also why trail running is so
valuable and wrestling with a human
opponent
what we're doing is creating robust
mental models so the movement is
already rehearsed in countless different
variations
i'd also like to take this further by
increasing the amount of variation
between and within
sets i talked about hybrid movements in
the 2020 batman training program
a movement like a renegade row is
extremely valuable because it involves
not only push-ups and rows
but also the transition between those
two movements the same goes for
something like a push-up into a hindu
push-up
into a burpee training out of sequence
like this also helps retention and
learning of new skills
this has been shown to be the case for
those practicing sports skills
here it's much more useful to train a
pass a dribble in a shot
rather than simply practicing shots or
passes for a defined chunk of time
this is called contextual interference
in contrast with chunking which is how
we typically train
by repeating a single movement over and
over and it makes sense
in the real world we don't chunk our
behaviors we need to be able to move
seamlessly from one to the other
completing a sequence of movements this
way also helps to keep us engaged as the
mind can't simply wonder
each movement must be crisp and sharp
and there must be no hesitation flowing
from one movement to the next
in an ideal world you'd respond to call
outs and attempt to transition quickly
as possible from one position to the
next
improving reaction times in a
multi-sensory three-dimensional space
this now becomes brain training as well
as physical training and more
importantly
it merges those two concepts remember in
my recent video on cognitive training we
discussed the importance of training
things like working memory
and likely other mental faculties in a
more 3d immersed environment
again this is where the sensory
integration comes into play which is how
the brain is
designed to operate and it's a world
apart from simply sitting in front of a
screen
and performing a dual n-back test it's
about viewing the entire system as one
cohesive whole
being able to use your physicality in
conjunction with rapid decision making
and awareness this has massive benefit
for athletes and of course
for batman again this should go at the
end of the workout things will be
rather cardio intensive and they won't
be the same focus on heavy repetitions
or complex movements
to stimulate hypertrophy and strength
gains
so these are the concepts behind the
2021 batman training program
that i'm dubbing the i am vengeance
workout if you want to see the full
version then head over to the website
where everything is listed in terms of
sets and repetitions
and split into a set number of days
these last two videos have been rather
big projects but i've really
appreciated all the support and the
fantastic response that these have
gotten
anyways next week i'm going to be
turning things down a little bit going a
bit back to normal
and among other things i'm going to be
discussing a functional training program
for complete beginners that means those
of us who can't even do a single push-up
i hope you found this one useful and
interesting guys a surprising number of
people have been following the
batman trading program from 2020 so i
hope that this will be
equally successful of course if you want
an even more in-depth training program
that's designed for
everybody then you can check out my
ebook and training program
super functional training that includes
a periodized
full program that focuses not only on
strength and
losing weight but also on mobility on
brain training
on explosiveness on on proprioception
and all the rest there's a discount on
that right now whilst we're all
struggling with the pandemic
alternatively you could pre-order my
upcoming book
functional training and beyond which is
a in-depth discussion
on the notion of functional training
it's available on amazon and many other
retailers you'll find links to that in
description down below
it comes out later this month in the us
and a little bit after that in
other countries and if you order it
right now there's a discount on
so you can benefit from that too thanks
again so much for watching these guys
i really appreciate it hope your 2021 is
off to a great start
and i'll see you next time thanks a ton
and bye for now
oh